à la lecture d'un rapport du département
américain à la santé on apprend que
washington a mené diverses actions pour
atténuer les efforts de pays comme la
russie qui tenteraient je cite
d'accroître leur influence dans la
région d'amérique du sud au détriment de
la sécurité des états unis
interrogé sur le sujet le porte parole
du kremlin n'a pas souhaité jeter
davantage d'huile sur le feu
je le répète encore une fois nous sommes
fermement opposés à ce que la situation
relative au vaccin soit politisée nous
estimons qu'il doit y avoir le plus
grand nombre possible de vaccins
différents pour que tous les pays y
compris les pays pauvres est une
possibilité de vacciner leur population
il est bon de noter que malgré les
pressions américaines brasilia s'est
tout de même engagé a commandé pas moins
de 10 millions de doses du vaccin russe
cependant sur le front européen le
spoutnik vais toujours à l'étude
toujours à l'examen du régulateur
européen des médicaments
l'europe doit fournir des informations
actualisées d'eric nous avons déposé
ensemble de documents le travail
à cet égard est en cours hier le fonds
russe d'investissements directs a
annoncé avoir passé des accords de
production du spoutnik v avec plusieurs
pays de l'union européenne plusieurs
pays dont la france cette annonce
intervient dans un contexte bien
particulier un contexte de pénurie de
vaccins mais aussi dans le cadre de la
suspension du vaccin britanno suédois
astrazeneca